I'm just saying that the Quran that was
come to us through the of course Allah
protected and these companions were mean
that came to us today that we recite was
thanks to the companions of the
restation and we know the Hadith comes
the same way you say no to Hadith but
you accept the Quran how do you answer
that contradiction then I started
finding a huge amount of Hadith which
totally contradict the Quran there were
10 then 100 okay you know what I'm going
to do brother give me your Facebook I'm
going to send you 2,000 I'll be back
here can you can open it just give me
one example regarding what regarding
what tell me brother vers is missing
were e there was NOS missing if if my
mathematic my mathematic timeable is
eaten by my dog I've memorized it please
this is a big insult just because the
chicken eat
it brothers and sisters just imagine for
a second that you give £10 in donation
and that £10 is used to buy food or
bricks or whatever to help the people in
Gaza but then just imagine this amazing
D that you want to do but we turn it
into a moneymaking machine how the W is
exactly that they take your money and
the money that we are going going to put
in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subhana bless and preserve you
guys
just insult the compion I don't know
compion can I can I ask you a question
go how did the Quran come to
us don't you know the vers
Allah no I'm asking a question how did
the Quran come to us like Quran so you
are going to come up with the technique
of it's sah who brought the they are the
one there the only one you have I'm
saying how did the Quran come to I'm
asking a question Allah waala the
Almighty all Omni poent yeah as he has
all the power yeah the the the Quran
came out through through jel
to under the protection of allaha and
then what we have we have afterwards
with the Quran they they exit with the
interpretation of the Quran turned up
with what they called Hadith and
everything and what we've done we just
done what the Jews done they have the
Torah they have the Babylonian the
I'm asking
question say as an explanation interpret
to the the Quran that I memorize today
how did it come to us like like from the
from the prophet how did it come to me
today all right what are you going to
tell me I'm not going to tell you
nothing I'm ask what you going to tell
me because I have to do always refer to
believe no I believe I'm asking a
question imagine I'm not a Muslim I'm
saying where did the Quran that I recite
today come to me how how it came through
through no I know that then to the
Prophet Muhammad sallam through muhamad
and muhamad was able to right did the
prophet give it to me huh did I meet the
Muhammad no okay how did I get the Quran
yeah how did I get the Quran but the
Quran is the revelation of God I know
but how did I get it coming it come from
God look I became a Muslim 11 years ago
I read the Quran realiz how did this
Quran come to me it didn't come for the
prophet Muhammad wasallam directly it
came through the sahab correct yes okay
so do you AC the Quran that's the only
thing we accept good okay so you're
telling me the Quran came from the
sahabah I accept the how did the Quran
come to me I'm asking you okay okay
okay that there is three centuries of do
do you know that what sahab have done
didn't
sahab
to down come down do you
know do you know you don't know I I
don't know
you don't I don't know that
me people three
people each other the biggest war which
Muslims Army put up was between Muslims
okay okay 125,000 against
95,000 and before
that 6,000 that's question so the sah
you're telling me because you have first
century second century third century
soal you
say that means whatever they say they
are straight
forward and they were fighting each
other they killed each other they
mistakes Beyond imagination asking thean
only thing which is we have to
go Allah calm down how did the Quran
that was given to the angel Gabriel the
angel Gabriel taught it to the prophet
Muhammed who did the prophet teach it to
who did the prophet sallam teach it to
the Quran the memorization who did he
teach it to okay they were around okay
he knew it by heart first
yes so he didn't have to produce an
effort to anything do not rush in
reciting it it is upon us to preserve it
in your heart okay who did he teach it
next after they memorize it okay was and
comp were around so did were the scribes
and they wrote it okay good so
companions wrote it down and memorized
it yes the Quran was memorized and
written down by the Companions and that
is they teach it to the and the they
reach us today correct okay so how did
it come to but there is the initial
verses of the Quran which Allah is going
to protect it so it's it's they were a
means those people were just means but
you have the All Pro the all who said in
the Quran in many many verses that I'm
going to protect this it won't
anything go back to Allah the almighty
the all knower the one who was in the
past is in the future in the parallel
world there is no time they put Allah
within a
time give him time
and Allah has no
time on a
throne on a throne ocean and he sits on
the left and moves to the right and tell
the prophet to sit on his right brother
can you one second I'm telling you I'm
telling you
brother one second one second you
admitted that the the prophet Muhammad
taught the companions the scribes who
was writing it down correct yeah they
taught as alternative they T no that's a
means no problem but Allah protected it
yeah by that when the battle what was
the battle that happened um when many of
the died which battle which was the
battle the died who many of the Quran
reciters which battle was it no
no which ble was it
one
no no what's the battle when the died
many of the of the Quran died what was
the Battle
called ble of Yama in the Battle of Yama
in the Battle of yamama many of the
companians died died yeah yeah yeah okay
abak and om this why they stop that war
because they realized this is the time
this is not the time of this is why can
brother I can you're not letting me talk
the point in AAL is this like you no
it's fine I just want to have a
respectful discussion I'm just saying
that the Quran that was come to us
through the of course Allah protected it
and these companions were means that
came to us today that we recite was
thanks to the companions of the
restation and we know the Hadith comes
the same way you say no to Hadith but
you accept the Quran how do you answer
that
contradiction okay I just I just
happened I'll be frank with you I'll be
straight forward I just want to know
what happened
is um I used I used to believe yeah in
the which
is that means the which doesn't
contradict the Quran okay then I started
finding a huge amount of Hadith which
totally contradict the Quran there were
10 and 100 thousand okay you know what
I'm going to do brother give me your
Facebook I'm going to send you 2,000
I'll be back here can you mention one
what open it just give me one example
regarding what regarding what you tell
me don't morality regarding regarding
woman regarding you know how many what
about don't you isn't that an atifi
Hadith that a
woman no no no okay good she she she
stops she stop so morality 1,000 do you
believe the prophet married Aisha at six
of course I don't believe okay why why
and you have
21 okay
good okay good and six years he was able
you know you know your issue is let me
tell you what your issue is insecurity
why insecurity let me tell you why
because any anytime I pedop why
insecurity one second they are saying
that he's a pedopile one second how can
you that's insecurity let me tell you
something I believe look let me tell you
what let's have a s discussion I believe
the prophet muhammedi wasallam married
Aisha at 6 and consed N I have zero
problem I speak to kufar who are enemies
of Islam who come to me W I explain to
them they say to me makes sense one
second one second one second I speak to
non-muslims they come to me and say did
you marry the prophet mared a 6 and 9
One Second One Second One Second One
Second One Second no of course of course
of course brother brother I give the
explanation I there's a video of mine
right the prophet's marriage to Aisha
I'm speaking to a non-muslim white guy
first he asked me in 10 15 minutes he
Sayes he make sense the point is the
following anytime I speak to people who
just follow the Quran the issue is a
insecurity isue I don't mean in a
disrespectful way which is the follow
the
prophet no one second just because the
prophet did something you are getting
this issue because of the current times
we live in because of the western world
and liberal values a 100 years ago
nobody ever had the issue with the
prophet Mar 6 for 1300 years no for 1300
years about
one I'm talking no I'm talking about
nol that's different brother brother my
friend that's different my argument is
the following whenever I speak to
quranist quranist they have an issue
they come and say I tell them okay do
you believe in stoning
adulterous this one as well do you
accept it what do you mean it's accepted
he has been eaten by a goat they said
the prophet had he was sent this verse
he he did enter his b a ding a ding
technically speaking is actually a
chicken but then again the
came up as a goat he was eaten by a goat
did the chicken eat his brain as well no
no no he he said they what is it in the
Quran is a ston in the Quan it was in
the Quran and and then it was they come
up with with from om no problem I know
even the verse of the Quran he haven't
I'm asking a simple question you believe
saying that he has been eaten by a goat
do you believe it or not how can I
believe something say I'm preserving the
Quran are you telling me it's not in the
Quran because he was eaten by God then
Allah hasn't the full full control of
things he let a goat come and
eat this this verses which are missing
brother vers is missing in the Quran
because they were eating there was no
vers missing so so if if my mathematic
my mathematic timetable is eaten by my
dog I've memorized it please this is a
big insult you just because the chicken
ate it I forgot said I protect so he
didn't protect he didn't protect Allah
didn't protect
abrogation it works there's abrogation
by writing AB by meaning
AB the abrogation ab an insecurity you
have you know
why you know what it is you you are
insecure because of the look look the
Western World look I don't follow the
Western World I follow Islam whatever
Allah says look in all my life come up
with you Bor musl you born a Muslim I'm
born a Muslim you are not I came 11
years ago yeah I have no I have never
had the issue with the prophet's
marriage to Aisha I have no problem with
going to
war do you accept do you accept the
prophet killed 600 yahood not again you
come up with it anything moral argument
is okay this story listen to this they
didn't want okay those people they
didn't want did he behe had 600 of them
or not you know what they say 600 yes
sometimes 800 sometimes 900
Prophet are saying the Jews themselves
they not saying it happen that's the
they you accept it we say yes in their
books
book they're saying that the prophet got
people okay and he was checking if they
have one pubic hair and who never had
one pubic hair he was cut to the sord
alhamdulillah and he was smiling C
alhamd babies alhamdulillah
babies whoever you can
have let me tell something let me tell
something Propet this is why you are
insecure my Prophet has killed this is
why you're insecure this is why you're
insecure let me tell you why look I
believe my
Prophet brother let me finish Prophet
brother let me finish the sword brother
said My Religion will be brother you
have insecurity complex my my Prophet
was killing smiling and laugh brother
brother brother this is what I'm saying
this is why I say is
Prophet I can't even speak brother let
me talk do you have can I talk do you
have can I talk in abundance can I talk
I talk no can I talk don't you have in
abundance our Prophet is a kill can I
talk can I reply thank you thank
you the argument I'm saying is very
simple my Prophet by the way and he's my
and he's my Prophet as well he's my
Prophet as well the argument is you're
your Senor of quranist meaning he only
accepts the Quran my argument is the
following because of liberal values and
the Western values he is like oh the
prophet married AA six oh I don't care
brother to me there's a perfect
explanation he has insecurity the
prophet didn't marry AA at n yes he did
when it came to the Battle of when it
came to the Battle of KHAK when the Jews
done a treachery there were 600 beheaded
I have no problem alhamdulillah I'm not
insecure about my religion told them
that they were young there were some of
them most of them were babies care
alhamdulillah I have no problem you're
insecure you know what's very funny you
claim you was born a Muslim I came to
live Islam 11 years ago I have zero I'm
not here to please anybody but Allah and
his messenger inshah brother you're so
insecure when let me finish but your
religion is based on let me finish
brother you let me finish brother
brother let me finish please let's have
a dialogue discussion you reject the
Hadith but you accept the Quran the
Quran came through the sahaba the Hadith
came through the sahaba you reject the
Hadith but you accept the Quran they
both came the same method you can't
answer it answer me how brother you
accept the Quran who came from the sah
but thei that came is say no how Okay
excuse me he's not saying
about can I
talk no no please
answer the word Hadith came up in the
Quran four times yes four times allaha
is he is relating to the Quran is
relating to him okay and then the word
Sunnah is is in the Quran five times and
then every time the word Sunnah is
relating to Allah there is Noah from the
propah of Allah
okay was used in the Quran five times is
referring to you didn't my
question related in the Quran four times
is related to Allah in the Quran you
don't exist you are a second Revelation
created fabricated okay you reach the
maximum it's about your end because what
you are you are the Blasphemous Bunch
you are Blasphemous people